We've talked before about how there are sort
of benign conspiracy theories and then there
are conspiracy theories and disinformation
that when people believe them have very, very
real, real world consequences.
And with coronavirus, the disinformation and
the conspiracies have very real repercussions.
If you don't accept the science and you don't
wear a mask and you don't social distance,
you keep having indoor gatherings, people
get the virus and some of them die.
The repercussions are very real.
Now, you might have heard that Utah's coronavirus
numbers are exploding so badly that the Republican
governor put in place more guidelines and
a masked man did it mandate and explained
that many hospitals are nearly full or completely
full.
Uta's case numbers have been spiking dramatically.
They're now up to about three thousand cases
a day.
That's a ton for a state with only three million
people in it.
Deaths are also up, although not as dramatically
for now as the cases, although that could
change as the hospitals are increasingly full.
We know that the death rate tends to go up
when that happens.
Well, there are people in Utah, one of the
most right wing states in the country, that
think it's all a lie.
What I mean is they don't even believe that
the full hospital is really full and certainly
not with coronavirus patients.
Conspiracy theorists started driving to Utah
Valley Hospital in Provo, Utah, claiming that
the parking lot is so empty the hospital can't
possibly be full of covid patients.
So what did they do?
They didn't just stay in the parking lot.
They invaded the hospital.
They entered with video cameras to document
what they believed would be a completely empty
intensive care unit.
Now, fortunately, these people did not actually
get access to the ICU.
That would have been just, you know, even
more insane.
But had they been able to get to the ICU,
they would have found a full ICU with coronavirus
patients, nurses and doctors and staff under
huge strain from dealing with a full ICU and
the pandemic.
Now, the reason that there weren't many cars
in the parking lot is because there are no
one huge restrictions on visitors at hospitals
right now because of the pandemic.
Also, many of the people in the hospital with
covid didn't drive themselves to the hospital
because they were too sick.
So they don't have cars.
Their guests aren't allowed.
So guests don't have cars there.
That's why the parking lot seems relatively
not full.
Things are so bad in Utah that they are recruiting
medical professionals from out of state to
come in and help and expediting credentialing
out of state medical professionals to be able
to work in Utah.
Imagine for a second if these people put as
much time and energy into coming together
to deal with the pandemic rather than invading
hospitals.
Imagine how much better off we would be.
Imagine if these people, when we learned about
the virus and understood that cases were rising
and how it spread.
Imagine if all of these so-called truthers
and skeptics and deniers actually did something
to help the situation rather than hurt it,
like distributing masks as an example or figuring
out, you know, a grocery delivery service
maybe for elderly folks who aren't as comfortable
with ordering Amazon fresh or delivery services
or whatever to get groceries delivered so
those folks could stay home and reducing the
number of elderly and at risk people who get
like I could go on for an hour just saying
almost anything that they even just staying
home themselves.
Right.
Almost anything they could have done other
than doing this skeptic's stuff and trying
to invade an ICU to get video of an ICU.
They doing nothing would be better than what
they are doing.
And imagine if these same people, these types
of people put as much time into dealing with
any societal problem.
Like if we had the conspiracy world dealing
with climate change, if we had the conspiracy
world deciding, hey, you know what, we're
going to eradicate hunger like anything, if
the conspiracy right.
Was helping us rather than working against
us, there are so many problems that we could
have solved at this point in time.
And it is really tragic.
And, you know, in the same way that I talked
about earlier, how do you deprogram 75, nearly
75 million Trampas?
And we talk about Trump ism as a cult.
And we've interviewed Steven Hassin about
how Trump ism is like a cult in many ways.
In that same way, how do you deprogram the
covid people now?
One of the things we have talked about is
when cultists and conspiracy theorists start
to see that their beliefs have consequences
at scale.
Sometimes that will deprogram them with covid.
There's a very clear path there, right?
It's I'm a Denyer relative, gets sick and
or dies from covid.
You were deprogrammed by seeing that your
skepticism at scale has conflict, has consequences
and that people die.
And we saw examples of that.
If you think back to the Democratic National
Convention, we there was a woman whose name
I forget now, but who spoke very passionately
about her father, who was a Trump supporter
almost to the very end, didn't believe that
the virus was serious, got covid and died,
and that this changed his world view.
It changed her world view and that of some
others.
It can happen.
But you still saw it.
Trump rallies even days before the presidential
election of a few weeks ago.
People with shirts that said, you know, my
my cousin died of covid and I still support
Trump.
I mean, like, you know, boisterously and extravagantly
and aggressively flaunting their ignorance.
Really, really sad stuff.
But this stuff has real consequences and we
are seeing it very much.